will smith news his movie Aladdin will
officially pass a billion dollars this
weekend and he seems to be pulling off a
genie like transformation in his new
movie Gemini man 2 and we're taking you
behind the scenes when I some don't see
a ghost
I play both 50 year-old Henry and 23
year-old jr. whose Santu killer
Will Smith faces off against a
picture-perfect clone of his younger
self in Gemini man this technology is
going to change how movies are made so
how they do it
filmmakers covered wills face in tiny
dots or markers and captured his every
emotion that the cutting-edge process
called digital creation what does that
mean wills 23 year old face is 100%
computer-generated
and a real throwback to his fresh prints
days meet casa su casa we were with will
back in 1991 when he was the same age as
his new virtual counterpart i couldn't
have played junior at 23 years old but
now i'm able to understand and capture
both characters because of the amount of
experience that I've had as an actor
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]